[Applause]
the son being a presence in the paint
doing the right thing matters play our
mellow get that ball goes to no look to
the corner gain set the screen now Bello
has been swallowed of the tooth of
peppers ovens oh say oh we - Bello like
this one strong strong lots of soda
status in the show does that hit
betting on the other side so let's open
it things up for Hassan download take
away two suitors but leave the Haitian
sensation all buttons but where your
help is all right he gives up baseline
and there's no help there
and when Dale comes over but hold me
yeah these these up is trying to walk
that off a the 14 hitters right here
gets him mid-range game and there's that
he is trying to get the block and fouls
him across the body
my mate he's had he's made three threes
all of those came early in the game
[Music]
well that's knocked away he grabs it
without traveling much purpose it
crowded and so he just rips and then the
threat of the drive is all
focusing up was a strong grip backs them
up
now he's vulnerable tries to close that
spit now draws the double atoms breathe
the shows now single coverage again it's
Anthony on percocet blogs by takes it to
the cup and slams it were to a no
special our time so Damien didn't go
directly to scale of all mellow captain
[Music]
low let's just wing and it's all quick
it's quick decision-making to back
daddy's young gone just enough
[Applause]
tries to cast back up into play but too
much space has been created Bella will
go to the line